Oh, Charlie!
What is it about dogs that brings us so much joy?
Well, hello.
Do you think I'm ridiculous? Throwing a party for my dog?
No!
I went to a doggie wedding last weekend and it was like surprisingly emotional.
Maybe it's because dogs are the most adorable creatures in the planet.
Her little face looks so angry and happy at the same time.
Whatever it is, dogs mean the world to us.
I wanna help you find your dog.
Hop on.
Are you out of your mind?
Gertrude, you look absolutely beautiful today.
This is not our dog.
This is our dog.
This dog has made us family.
Every spot that you've sniffed on this entire walk is the same.
Just pee anywhere!
Dogs open their hearts to us to love and to be loved.
And I find that beautiful.